despite a large buildup of forces on the
ukrainian border russia says it has no
plans to invade u.s president joe biden
isn't convinced there will be enormous
consequences
if he were to go in and invade as he
could the entire country
or a lot less than that as well
for russia not only in terms of
economic consequences and political
consequences but will be enormous
consequences worldwide this would be the
largest if he were to move in with all
those forces to be the largest invasion
since world war ii it would change the
world weapons are already being shipped
to kiev part of a 200 million dollar u.s
aid package and more marines are being
sent to protect the embassy in the city
if russia decides to come into ukraine
it will be a disaster for russia 8500
u.s troops are on heightened standby
ready to move at short notice if
european nato allies need backup they
won't be going to ukraine joe biden held
a video conference with european allies
to show up support for diplomatic and
economic responses his actions getting a
surprise vote of confidence from
republicans on capitol hill they're
prepared
to
take steps
before
an incursion not afterwards
i've not been near the news this morning
so i'm not sure what additionally
may have occurred
but it appears to me the administration
is moving in the right direction but
there are calls for stronger action
against russia now saying this acts as a
warning to others so sanction him now
build up nato
and not do not give into this bully
if we get ukraine right
it can reset the world
if we get it wrong
god help taiwan
the white house says it will continue to
give classified briefings on the hill as
the situation develops biden determined
to put on a united front in the first
real big foreign policy test of his
presidency alan fisher al jazeera
washington